i joined caldera and then managed to get
this
project off the ground at cloudera so
this is basically the genesis of apache
impala
[Music]
marcel thank you for joining us at 20
minute leaders
michael thanks for having me of course
it's very gracious for you to give us
your time i know how busy you are
and uh you know i i would just love to
go ahead and get right into tell us a
little bit about
your background where you came from and
i'd love to go all the way up to
the founding of apache impala sure
happy to uh how far back do you want me
to want me to go how i ended up in the
us
let's start let's start all the way
there sorry that's benny my new
my new dog he's just saying hi
hello benny hi benny say hi okay i'm
gonna go and meet while you talk just
let him if he barks
of course of course no worries so i
ended up coming over here
because i was um i was a um a student
in computer science in hamburg
university of hamburg which is where i'm
from in germany
and i was very interested in databases
and in the work that michael
stonebreaker did
so i found a way to come over
to berkeley as an exchange student and i
ended up
basically showing up on stone breaker's
doorstep
in his office and asking if i can do
volunteer work
which i then ended up doing so i ended
up doing some bug fixing on postgres
and became part of the
ended up being a staff programmer in his
research group
and that was back in the mid 90s
and then i left in order to finish my
degree in germany
and then reapplied as a regular grad
student so this is how i
uh ended up as a grad student at
berkeley and i'm very grateful
you know that i actually had that
opportunity and um
mike stonebreaker had been helping me a
great deal
so um i was then my professor then was
joe hellestine stone breaker had left
and gone to mit
and as i was his first grad student i
i graduated in 2000 that's when i got my
phd
um and then started working at a bunch
of
database related startups but in the so
in the early 2000s it was a
combust years and i had um a total of
four jobs in three years the companies
went out of business or you know things
like that happened
um so it was kind of a dicey time
and so it's pretty much the same as
today's
software engineer when they bounce from
from companies except back then it
wasn't your decision it was because the
companies
basically you know let me find a new job
um
while i'm on my h-1b uh so it was a
little dicey but
eventually i joined google and so i
ended up at google in 2003
and was working there took a little
break from databases before then i had
only worked on database internals
and execution and um
started working on the ad serving system
and seeing database technology
more from a user's perspective so and i
i then
became um i then started to appreciate
uh different aspects of it previously i
had only worked on database technology
from the producer perspective and you
basically you
work on shrink package software and then
but you never see it deployed and how
it's being used right so really
so maybe outline quickly the difference
between between
the two types of consumers from the
producer side and from the consumer side
of databases
uh how is that different well as an
engineer
i never had any touch points with
the uh users of the software that i
wrote basically that was like
far away right i guess there were some
sales people and their sales engineers
and all that stuff
i was far away from that so i didn't
really see it
and at like i said at google you know we
um
in ads there was a chart at my sql setup
and so you start appreciating
what really matters in a production
environment and i also
um in particular predictability and
reliability are two
um two different two things and also
breadth right what i saw there
was um google was basically using
their shot at my sql setup both as an
operational data store which
it's where all the ads um the adwords
metadata went
but also as an analytic data store
because
all of the um usage like the click and
impression data
and the aggregates out of it were all
rolled up and were
were transferred into the same system
and so
there was a data warehouse and there was
an etl pipeline into the data warehouse
but it wasn't very well maintained and
people didn't really like to use it
because it was always out of date people
really liked the conflict
we're looking really at the early days
of google ads right
oh yeah yes we're looking 2003 2004
right this is a
while back um now things are different
obviously of course yeah and
we'll get to that as well but so that
was kind of a i want to say an aha
moment
that what really mattered there was the
um
the breadth of the workloads the
flexibility
that the data management system gives
you in terms of the workloads that you
can run on it and the more workloads you
can run on it the better
right this was basically meant you
didn't have to
um etl the data you didn't have to copy
the data again you didn't have to
do things with it again in order to have
it be useful
so that in my mind is one of the key
criteria for what makes a database
system or the data management system in
general
useful for a company for a business
right
let's sort of fast forward from here and
you are about to create
you know one of the in my mind one of
the most revolutionary technologies
in the database world and that i also
had
had the pleasure of using quite a bit so
talk to me a little bit about this this
idea behind apache impala and
and and what's been happening what
happened in the years to come with it
absolutely um i'll i'll actually go back
a little bit to the
sort of founding ideas i was then ended
up being
a google then an ads did a
new internal database system called f1 i
was the
tech lead for the query engine side of
that and
i thought that was such an interesting
and revolutionary system
that i uh left google and i wanted to do
something like that outside of google so
i joined cloudera yeah that was kind of
the
the um the motivation i joined calgary
and then
managed to get this project off the
ground at cloudera so this is basically
the genesis of apache impala
and back then you know the world was
talking about hadoop
hadoop was actually an interesting
technology i think the
from the technical side people made a
lot about out of mapreduce
and things like this but the real driver
was really the commoditization of
storage
and how all of a sudden hadoop made
very cheap and with very cheap storage
people started building data lakes
and so going back to the idea of
flexibility
it seemed um completely natural that you
would still want to do analysis
and you want to do analysis still with
the tools you have right
there is a very large ecosystem that has
grown around sql
both from the data management side as
well as the
um the user angle which is bi tools
right they all rely on sql
so it's clear to me that this wasn't
going to go away and that the ability to
collect
more and more data means that you want
to do more and more analysis not less
what now what here about are we talking
here we're now talking 2011.
okay now i do want to point out then you
know 10 years ago it wasn't very clear
to everybody that
you want to do this right i mean it was
you're saying it was clear to you but it
wasn't clear to the world necessarily
it was i think um if you look back i
think the world started talking a lot
about mapreduce and things like this and
no sequel there was a lot there was a
lot of big push
around no sql data stores but i think
if you look back even farther from a
historical perspective
sql was what made analytics and
analytics stores
possible but before sql existed
there was no such thing as bi tools
because
writing a moderately complex query that
does an aggregate and maybe three joins
writing that against a record api which
is basically what nosql system is
is extremely time consuming right so
sure
if you if you don't have declarative
queries
um which today means sql you don't
really have analytics so it was clear
that uh and also going back to to google
right 80 of the traffic on the data or
90 of the traffic was analytic traffic
right you can always
you can write only so much data but you
can read the data and analyze it
10 times over right so it was clear that
analytic traffic would always dwarf the
actual update traffic
so to me it was clear that this was
still extremely useful technology
uh parallel database systems and that
there would be absolutely a need to have
that in this new hadoop
world so that was basically the the
driver
behind saying we're going to do a polyp
okay so now so now just
give us a brief overview what is impala
for anybody who doesn't who doesn't know
the
little details about it sure impala is a
query engine at you know at the most
high level at the highest level
um it is an implementation of parallel
database technology
so the idea that you have when you have
a large collection of data
you have it sitting in a um in a data
store
the data store can be accessed let's say
you know back in the days you had it
sitting on hard drives
you can have multiple computers talking
to it and you can process the data in
parallel this is the idea of a scale out
parallel database system and there have
been other implementations of that since
impala was the um the first one in the
hadoop space
that i would want to say took
performance seriously so
we departed from the standards
approach um and did it in
c plus plus number one we were the first
ones to
also do it with runtime code generation
right from the outset
and we used llvm for that purpose and i
think all those things contributed to
the
eventual success of the project so the
the focus on performance
which was very clear um you know given
the growing
size of data it was very clear that you
needed to have a performance system in
order to analyze it
so right and then so how how did it
scale and
how did you even get people to start
using it outside of of where you are so
obviously
it served your purposes but you know
obviously it it went into
so many developers tool sets it's
i mean we ended up uh open sourcing it
after the initial version it was open
source i think that's obviously a big
driver behind that right
um it could be adopted by non-commercial
entities
people could fork it or you know use it
for their own production
purposes um whatever else so i think
that's an obvious key
key element for getting adoption outside
of even then when you open source
something i mean it doesn't necessarily
you know the competition on github now
to get the stars
and it's not it's not that easy to get
recognition for all the things that
you're doing so
was there any strategy behind getting it
out there or did you just release it and
say you know what
it's good maybe maybe people will start
using it and adopting it
that's that's basically that wasn't
really a strategy to be honest around it
we just put it out there and we um
worked on making it better right
obviously there was a the commercial
angle which was
cloudera customers yeah asking for
features improvements etc
and then those improvements all made it
into the public domain code base
and i think eventually it was just
recognized that it's a high quality high
performance system
and you know that's something a lot of
people need
so yeah that's why white and i ended up
seeing adoption
so i'm i'm very heavily invested into
into
working with data right now both in both
with machine learning at stanford but
also and as
just a software engineer and i'd love to
get your two cents on where are we
headed
in terms of databases and in terms of
how we how we think of data and store
data um
you know it's still today we are still
we still are kind of
feeling limited by the amount of data
that we can store and i have to be
conscious of how
how much am i enlarging and populating
my data sets before i start incurring
some some big charges you know even on
my
gcp or aws so what do you see this
eventually not being an issue or are we
going to see some different ways of
storing our data
i think i mean just talking about cost
obviously the cloud providers
are working on technologies that make it
cheaper to store
data primarily by tiering it based on
usage patterns right right um that said
you know if you compare storage costs
today
in the cloud to what you paid 10 years
ago when you bought a san or something
like this right when you bought
enterprise storage
it's a lot cheaper already of course i
think the big
thing here that you see today is again
flexibility right the ability
to first dump your data without
buying and then paying for it
incrementally right you i'm paying for
what i'm storing
i'm not paying for a gigantic storage
array
before i use any of it right so i think
right i think that is a big driver and i
think this also informs database
technology right i think the
um you still have data warehouses
as a cornerstone of how data is
managed and consumed today yeah but
you can also see you know what started
with hadoop the idea of the data lake
becoming
more and more popular the idea that you
can aggregate and accumulate data
before maybe deciding on um
do having a heavily curated schema sure
um before
centralizing everything in a siloed data
warehouse
right which in my mind uh data warehouse
technology is sort of a relic from the
uh 2000s that's really how it started
out right back in the days you had
resource constraints
and you needed to separate your
operational data store from your
analytic data store and this is how the
data warehouse was born
but there is much less of a need for
that a technical need for that today
and again going back to the aspect of
flexibility
um every business needs flexibility no
business is set in stone
and the ability to basically accumulate
data
collect data and then later on decide
what am i going to do with it
and then also add resources based on
what you want to do with it
i think that is going to become a game
changer for database technology so in
that sense i think
seeing cloud databases
and cloud analytics services
is you know becoming so popular
is an outgrowth of that right the desire
for
flexibility so what gets you excited now
you know it's 2020. it's been quite a
few years since safaichi impala where
where are you now
i'm still excited about uh like i said
continuing on the trajectory of
flexibility so making
database technology ever more accessible
outside of a traditional data warehouse
environment
so i think this is kind of what i'm
pushing towards and also what i'm
currently working on so that's one thing
i think more
data lake analytics is here to stay and
it's going to become
more and more of a force i think so
that's that's one direction that i'm i'm
also excited about it because
i think it changes the user experience
so far
you still have um i want to say the data
warehouse user experience is still
shaped by
the technology from the 2000s right the
when you have these heavily siloed
systems
and i think um bit by bit
that becomes less and less technically
necessary
and so going to a user experience where
you can get analytic functionality
regardless of how you collect and store
data
right you don't have to decide in
advance so i need to transform
everything into a column store
and dump all my data into a data
warehouse right you
you're kind of getting away from that
yeah i'm saying wherever i have
wherever i have meaningful business data
i should be able to do something with
it definitely definitely so i i know i'm
thank you again for your time and we're
just about
to reach 20 minutes and uh one of the
things that i love doing is
i love asking the different thought
leaders three words that best describe
them or how they would like
others to describe them and i and i find
it very interesting
to sort of look back now and see how you
know both the similarities and
differences
from tech world to the entrepreneurship
world
to the no education world and if you're
comfortable with that i'd love to also
hear
what three words you think best describe
yourself what three words
okay um i guess that's also
it's probably three words that others
would use or that i would use i'll stop
being myself
um i would call myself thoughtful and
uh premeditated nice um
and analytical very very cool
marcel thank you very very much for
taking the time to do this all right
thank you and look forward to speaking
again
definitely stay safe and stay healthy
bye bye
you